every single Sucker Punch they throw at
me for the rest of human time I can sit
with any of these clowns and no matter
who they sit with with their research
team whatever garbage they come up with
I'm like a fool of all of them but why
am I even entertaining them anymore
what's the point that was the last
chance I gave mainstream media they lied
for months to get that interview with me
completely dishonest head to toe and
like you said they sit with Philip are
you okay are you okay we heard your
mom's upset that poor old lady maybe
everyone should stop talking about it
because his mom's upset let's not talk
about it anymore because his mother's
old you're either part of the club or
not you have to sell your sanity
nowadays if you sell your sanity your
afforded protections that's the reality
of it because if you're a same thinking
person you don't buy their [__] and
that's what upsets them they don't want
anybody who thinks for themselves they
need you to not they want you to believe
exactly what's on the television screen
believe in covid it's covet now it's
covered now oh Putin's invaded Ukraine
Putin's cured covid now now it's it's
insane until the next thing comes it's
absolutely asinine did any of the
questions that they sent you ahead of
time Zero by the way we didn't there was
no
I need to pause this for one second just
to tell you that there's some of them
made an account called denalva de Nova
the chat made account called denalva de
Navidad oh that's cute you know I must
say guys don't give her more attention
but it's a good thing you know what I
mean when even when Jenny did all of her
videos about me I'm like wow is that
really like how much like my presence
hits people yeah I know I actually did a
video on you too I'm one of the hair the
hair you look completely different and
you're way nicer in person she's a nice
person I look like a [__] but I'm
actually really nice you look on camera
you do but you are actually a real
sweetheart I'm surprised I know most
people get surprised they're like oh wow
I don't mean to understand
more than Elvis Pearl trying to get your
attention
[Laughter]
did they ask you any of the questions
they said they were going to ask zero
they start with an attack and it became
a battle into did they ask you at any
point what jail was like your mental
health was like zero how like you
completely missed the mark when everyone
wants to know what was jail like but
they don't even ask you that question
this is what's so interesting about it
these people are so detached from
reality because they are genuinely
detached in reality they think that
finding a video I made eight years ago a
four-hour speech I made eight years ago
and finding one line of it without
context that can be misconstrued they
think that sitting down with me and and
saying that to me is an aha moment
nobody cares because they're taken out
of context one and I said you're taking
things out of contest she goes I'm not
taking out a context I said you're
presenting it without context that's
taking it out of context that's what it
is you're lying by Omission I said that
to her after the camera's off and she
looked at me because she didn't
understand when you omit details when
you refuse to put in all of the details
who can Lie by including one detail
which may happen to be true you can tell
the truth and miss all the details
around the truth and you are lying by
Omission you're lying by omission and
you're sitting here saying oh you said
this eight years ago nobody cares
because they know me and they know I
didn't mean it in that way and they know
what's taken out of context and they
know that it's an old video on the
internet and it's not even an aha moment
they think it is but they just want to
sit with you for an hour attack you and
attack you and attack you wait for you
to make one mistake if I would have
stuttered or made a single mistake
that's the only three minutes they would
have shown that's all they want they
want that one hour then they take the
little bit with me they cut it down to
12 minutes they look terrible in all of
it but I've already made a single
mistake would have been the only bit
they've shown that's all they care about
fake news did you tell them did you say
I'm only doing this if I'm able to
record as well I said I know that's what
happened with Trump as well a couple
years ago I didn't even tell them I just
recorded it okay so they didn't know you
were recording they didn't know I was
recording until afterwards and then I
said that was dishonest I'm going to
release the whole video you told them
before you released I told them there is
no contract or agreement with BBC no
nothing was signed it was just simply a
an interview okay because I think that
was very important when you released it
for people to see what fully was said
versus and by the way you know the
Phillips Schofield the interview that
they put up the 12-minute I just came
out you know the comments are turned off
of course they are the comments are
turned off yours are turned on this is
turned off uh and and who knows many
reasons why they would do that but go
back go back to BBC so okay they come
they want to ask the questions of you
for some of the people that maybe aren't
following the story closely but they
know who you are we're in the car we're
driving and a lot of people are asking
questions we asked the drivers like hey
are you going to Tate's Place how do you
know we're going to take place
your whole state or Andrew Tate oh tell
us what I undertake well they said okay
what kind of a guy is he he's actually
really like him I said why do things
going through what he's going through
right now oh it's because it's always
because of money okay so we're at a
different restaurant so tell us why are
you going through this why is it going
everybody's saying a similar thing about
this right but for those who don't know
there's three different camps yeah the
camp that already sees you guilty it
doesn't matter what they read so for
example this story here you know from
BBC came out just last night 10 30.
Andrew Tate choked me until I passed
that UK woman claims right this is Alice
another anonymous name just like Sophie
right but there's three camps there's
those that say well look I'm already
thinking he's guilty I don't like him
anyways I need anything to get me to
think he's guilty whatever it takes I
don't have to I don't have to do my own
due diligence I just have to hear
anything then there's a camp that's a
die-hard fan there's nothing you can do
that they did wrong you can you know the
Indira is going to be wrong then you
have the people in the middle that are
the reasonable ones yeah that are saying
you know what let me look at this what
about this what about that the people in
the middle may say the following
question they may say and I may have
asked this question from you last time
as well they may say Andrew okay if this
guy is so innocent how can they get you
to go to the dungeon for 92 days how can
they put you on house arrest how can
they do all this stuff if you're
somebody that was born in the U.S you
lived in UK how come somebody else isn't
coming to bail you out you got different
lawyers how is it that they can keep
doing this to you if you're not guilty
what do you say to those people yeah and
once again I have to be careful what I
say because of the court case but
Romania has a law or the law in Romania
is basically if you can prove to a judge
that it might have happened they're
allowed to hold you up to six months
during the investigation stage if I was
guilty of anything I would have been
charged long ago and we're going to talk
about charges soon because I I still
believe they're going to attempt to
charge me but we're now approaching the
end of the six months they can keep me
under a form of arrest for without
charge
typically in Romania when I was first
arrested
the guard said ah within two weeks
you'll have your indictment it was like
two weeks ago yeah everyone gets charged
quickly nobody Waits six months for a
charge if they arrest you they charge
you like like every other country right
the fact they've waited six months and
gone into my entire life and attempted
to to find something shows they don't
have a case why I believe it happened is
because they didn't have a case when
they were trying to hit me with this
garbage and they thought you know what
if we put him all over the news
if we slander his name completely if we
if you're a girl who's going to hurt my
undertake call this number
so they were tempting
find what they wanted months go by
months go by months go by case File is
empty nothing's happening my lawyer's
saying when we can close this case File
like yeah we're just waiting for some
papers we're going to close it we're
going to close we're going to close it
around the time I was canceled
things start appearing in the case File
again they start spying on me again
very interesting that it happened around
that time
I don't know if they understood that I
didn't have I wasn't protected by the
political class of the USA I don't know
what happened
they started to build this case and they
spied on me for all of these months
spending millions of Euros spying on me
everywhere I went trying to find
evidence of the crime
eventually they get to the end of their
legal limit spy on me and they don't
have any crime they don't have anything
so in my current court case we have two
Americans who lied the ones who we have
the conversations between them saying
they're going to an Oscar for lying to
the police we have the ccdb of them
coming and going we have their Uber
records showing they can travel the
country freely we have their phone calls
with their mother where they're saying
yeah he didn't hurt me and my boyfriend
called me that we have all of it we
we have those two
and then there's nobody else who could
possibly even take the stand I don't
believe as as as high level as this
Matrix attack is I still don't believe a
Romanian judge is going to put me in
jail with the dossiers I've seen it it's
garbage I don't think I'm gonna end up
in jail but it's just taking years of my
life damaging my influence to having bad
things to say about me keeping me under
control keeping me locked in a house
that's all they want to do they have no
interest in the truth there's no victims
there's no one to take the stand do you
know who Sophie is or Alice is or no
yeah so the BB's silly that's really
interesting so then the BBC says well we
found victims because the BBC have done
enough investigative journalism to
understand that the case is garbage and
they have this no victims so they said
well we found victims
they found one called Sophie first that
was a few months ago I think I was still
in jail and Sophie appeared is that her
real name no that's her thing so they
have a girl with a fake name called
Sophie they don't show her face
they they ask me what do you think about
Sophie how can I comment on Sophie when
Sophie isn't real first person you've
made a rock secondly I don't know who
you're talking about you're saying that
nine years ago I was emotionally
controlling that is the most subjective
garbage accusation what does that mean
nine years ago I said you shouldn't
party with those guys in the club is
that what I said I don't know what I
said I don't know who she is if she
exists at all and they're saying nine
years ago you're emotionally controlling
Sophie said so who's Sophie we're not
telling you what's emotionally
controlling mean we're not telling them
what do you what comment do you want if
this person even exists which they don't
then I destroy the BBC make it very
clear to them that Sophie doesn't exist
on repeat because she doesn't and two
days later Alice appears what's
interesting about this is that decal the
federal agency inside of Romania along
with help from International Partners
have tried so hard spending millions of
Euros with Federal level tools to find a
victim so they can put me in jail and
they can't find anyone but the BBC just
pulls them up whatever they want the BBC
does where do these people come from and
I say this every single time if anybody
believes they've been wronged male or
female by me go to the police go to the
police I encourage you to go to the
police all these people say we don't
want to go to the police
we just want to say on the news what is
that because you're not real is that why
that's pretty convenient I mean if I was
a bad person why don't you go to the
calls oh because you have no evidence
and it doesn't exist that's why are all
these accusers in the UK not even in
Romania not even Romania so Sophie and
Alice is supposedly both from the UK and
Alice's story to correct that's not Al I
said Alice it's Evie Evie or Evie or
something like that e-v-i-e it's all
made up names it's all made up yes
Evie is saying 13 years ago I choked her
or something yeah by the way when is the
six-month time limit and did this come
okay and can we reference the Tweet you
just posted a couple days ago I want to
stay on the show's commenting on Evie
you were going to say something about
Evie uh what she said 10 so she's
claiming 10 years ago or 13 years ago
you guys had the consensual sex the
first time she comes back for the second
time around according to the story she
says she was being uh uh your hand was
on her throat strangled me she was
passed out for a minute and then she
came back and she said I did not approve
of the second time time having sex after
she was passed out so these stories
they're making you know and then she
says the guy asks a question and saying
how come you didn't do any police report
back then it says well because it's not
fully rape and it's not bad because it
was consensual I kind of wanted to be
there and I didn't tell anybody about it
six years later there's way too many
things that doesn't give it credibility
for somebody to say I didn't do anything
about it then but six years later I told
my friends three or six years later yeah
and this is the thing that's scary if
you say to any red-blooded male 13 years
ago you had sex with a woman
consensually and she's now unhappy about
how that sex happened you can get any
man on Earth can get screwed to that if
this person exists at all
get in line baby
laughs
[Music]
yeah there would be a lot of there would
be a lot of complaints bro listen when
have you ever heard what have you ever
met a girl and she's like I love my ex
he was a great guy it just didn't work
out
no toxic he was a narcissist he abused
me he kicked my dog you know it's just
endless endless smear and that like I
got so much Flack when I don't like just
automatically believe a girl it's crazy
if you even quite like if someone's
story just doesn't make sense like this
one girl oh my gosh she just got
divorced right and she had this whole
story about how the like the husband
left her high and dry and she went off
to us like like and she took the kid
because he was a deadbeat and then she
would say oh but I didn't trash him and
I'm like well how did you not track him
you just called him a deadbeat and all I
said on social media was we should
really hear his side of the story and
Destiny all these big streamers started
coming at me
yeah and say thing that like that I'm I
just all you do is only hear them hear
the woman's side I'm like I heard her
side I watched the 45 minute video she
made about her ex-boyfriend and I almost
think we should believe people less that
do that stuff because it's very like
attention seeking yeah because they've
learned because the thing is this too
like that used to be all the rage like
the 80s and the 90s like one woman came
out and started crying and then you got
these evil [__] at home like I hate
my husband like I can [__] I could do
this too and then now they all like I
said copy pasta do you know one thing I
also realized that if Andrew hate wasn't
like um a celebrity if he wasn't famous
I didn't think this woman would actually
come out because you know what the world
we're living right now everyone wants to
be famous everyone wants in any way they
can so it's like when you get famous
people just come up and make up a lot of
stories sometimes yeah they're true so
if because he was a let's say he was a
Debbie back then in the day why didn't
she complain but all of a sudden now
he's famous everyone knows him on
YouTube all of a sudden you remember oh
my God that helped me past that I want
to go say something to the police oh now
I'm angry he chokes me you will die
[Music]
I know that maybe it might be true but
then again it's like they're taking
advantage that's what people would see
us even if it does happen it's like I'll
feel bad for them but then I'm feeling
like you're just taking advantage of
this man dude you doing it for what
you're getting out of it because if you
are genuinely sad about what happened to
you you would say something and and all
the Western world as well where you can
say that the Lord favors the women in
the western world and it does favor that
women outside so if this happened like
let's say like this happened in Nigeria
I feel like a lot of women would not say
nothing because they're like people are
going to be like look at you less but
this is a Western World people just if
you go say something to the police the
women are always right so like that's
what I think that's like that's what it
just happens in general it just happens
it happened to Pearl when she popped off
everybody from her past is like oh Pearl
is terrible to me happened to me
recently some lose user that I took into
my life felt sorry for tried to lift
them up now he wants to try to like
expose me because he's a loser English
teacher you know all this stuff happens
when people rise to the top
right and you have people in your past
who feel jealous or they feel angry that
they weren't able to ride your coattails
up to fame or Glory they get entitled
they feel
they feel like you were started in the
same place and then you became
successful so then it's like they get
like jealous and then it's like they had
all these issues with you but not when
you were not when you were present
that's not what you're present and
that's the thing it's like we're so
quick to believe people that like tell a
story online when you realize it's like
attention seeking especially people that
make like a full it's one thing if it
comes up in a conversation you know like
within the age of live stream like stuff
comes up right yeah but I'm like this
girl made a 45 minute video about her
ex-husband and then she's like well I
had to I'm a public figure no you don't
you didn't you start like any any like
words that I've ever said about like an
ex-boyfriend online I have regretted
saying because I'm just like I shouldn't
have said anything even with anything
even with Crowder's wife like she was
sitting on that footage what was that
from 2021 yeah two years ago and she's
like okay now I'm spited and I'm gonna
release this out of nowhere like come on
well and it's and a lot of times it's
the same story like and that's why when
she was saying he was a deadbeat I
didn't believe it because again and and
you know people say it's anecdotal but
like you start to notice patterns and I
start doing this divorce documentary
where I interview men that like don't
get custody to the kit of the kids and
it's so common where the woman says he's
a deadbeat when really she's not letting
them like I think it's a myth the
deadbeat dad I think it's much more
common for women to use the kids as a
tool